- [Instructor] What are the
first three non-zero terms
of the Maclaurin series for the function
f of x is equal to x cosine of x?
So, one thing that you're
immediately gonna find,
let's just remind ourselves
what a Maclaurin series looks like.
So, our f of x can be
approximated by the polynomial,
we're gonna evaluate f at zero, that's why
it's a Maclaurin series, it's
gonna be centered at zero,
it's a Taylor series centered at zero.
Plus f prime
of zero times x
plus the second derivative
evaluated at zero
times x squared over two
plus the third derivative
evaluated at zero
times x to the third over three factorial,
we could view this as
two factorial as well,
and we keep going on
and on and on forever.
And, what you're
immediately going to find,
is when you start taking
the derivative of f
and then the second and the third
and the fourth and the fifth derivative,
you're actually gonna have to take
a bunch of derivatives here.
Every time you're going to
have to apply the product rule,
this is going to get very
hairy, very, very fast.
So, there's actually a
trick to this problem.
What we wanna do, we
could find the Maclaurin,
we can find the first three non-zero terms
of the Maclaurin series for cosine of x,
and then just multiply that by x, because,
x cosine of x,
you could view as the same
thing as x times the--
or another way of saying it is:
the first three terms of the
Maclaurin expansion for this
is just going to be x
times the first three terms
of the Maclaurin
expansion for cosine of x.
So, let's do that.
So, to do that, let's just
think about the various
derivatives of cosine of x.
So, if f of x,
I'm gonna use a different
letter here for the function.
If g of x is equal
to cosine of x,
then g of zero
is going to be equal to one.
And then the first derivative
would be equal to negative sine of x,
so the first derivative
evaluated at zero is zero
sine of anything, or
negative sine of anyth--
of zero I should say, is gonna be zero.
And the the second derivative,
well, derivative of sine is cosine
so it's negative sine,
so it's negative cosine of x.
And so, the second
derivative evaluated at zero
is going to be equal to negative one,
you might start seeing a pattern here.
The third derivative of x
is equal to sine of x
and so if I evaluate the
third derivative at zero
I'm gonna get zero again.
And then, when I take
the derivative of this,
when I take the fourth derivative,
I get back to cosine of
x, the fourth derivative
is the same thing as the function.
So, the fourth derivative
evaluated at zero,
this is also going to be
the fourth derivative--
I'll write it like
that--evaluated at zero.
This is also going to
be the fifth derivative
evaluated at zero, this cycles.
This is going to be the sixth derivative
evaluated at zero.
This is going to be the seventh derivative
And so, what are the first
three non-zero terms?
Well, let's see, it's gonna be this one.
It's going to be this one.
And, it is going to be this one.
And so, we're gonna have this term,
or let me just do it for cosine of x.
So, let me write this
down, so I'm gonna write--
and you might already know
the first three non-zero
terms of the Maclaurin
series for cosine of x,
but I'm finding it here for us--
so cosine of x is approximately equal to
the first term here is
just cosine of zero,
so that's just one.
And then, the next one is going to be
our second derivative,
so it's minus one
over two factorial
times x squared--this
is the one that involves
the second derivative--x squared.
And then, we're going to
involve the fourth derivative,
and the coefficient's one so it's gonna be
plus one
over four factorial
times x to the fourth.
If it involves the fourth derivative,
it's gonna be divided by four factorial,
it's going to be times x to the fourth.
And there you have it.
These are the first three non-zero terms
of the Maclaurin--oh sorry!
These are the first three
non-zero terms of the Maclaurin
series for cosine of x,
and so then we can say x cosine of x.
So, x times cosine of x.
I'm just gonna multiple
each of these things by x.
So, one way to think about it,
I'm multiplying both
sides of this times x.
So, I'm getting x minus
one over two factorial,
times x to the third power,
plus one over four factorial,
times x to the fifth power.
And we're done.
And even though this
might have seemed a little
hairy and a bit of a long process,
some people have it somewhat
committed to memory,
what the Maclaurin series
expansion of cosine of x
and sine of x are, and
sometimes e to the x, as well.
And then, this could
be a very fast process
where you just multiply that by x.
But, as you can see, even
finding that Maclaurin series
expansion for cosine of x isn't too bad.
If you'd done it the other
way, if you'd just tried
to take the first, second,
third, fourth, fifth,
or all the way to the
fourth derivative of this
and evaluated zero it would've gotten
very, very, very hairy.